les policiers y redoutent ils redoutent
les retenues les retenues redoutent les
policiers ça crée une ambiance
explosive dans les dans les centres de
rétention
et personne les policiers entre le moins
possible et on leur demande d'entrer le
moins possible dans les zones de vie
donc les arrivants sont arrivés avec
leurs paquetage à la porte fermée de la
zone de vie qui s'ouvre ils sont envoyés
là-dedans tout seul et c'est aux anciens
de leur apprendre ce qui va se passer
là-dedans les portes ne sont pas fermées
les portes des chambres donc il y a des
intrusions nocturnes et c'est un peu la
loi du plus fort qui règne
je rappelle également que
la rétention administrative nous coûte
très cher
d'après la Cour des comptes elle elle
coûte 690 euros par jour et par retenu
c'est un chiffre dont André et moi on
est allé demander des comptes à la Cour
des comptes en disant mais vous avez
écrit ce chiffre vous pouvez nous
expliquer comment vous allez sortir
alors ils ont pas pu nous le détailler
ce que je trouve un peu dommage on a
tous un peu dommage mais ils
maintiennent ce chiffre et disent qu'il
est exact en tout cas je rappelle que la
rétention elle est prévue pour être pour
le temps strictement nécessaire à
l'éloignement comme vous le savez
le ministère de l'Intérieur ne publie
plus le chiffre des
OCC qui sont délivrés
et pourquoi et pourquoi parce que on
verrait le ratio entre le nombre d'occf
et le nombre de d'éloignements réalisés
et je crois que
frôle péniblement les 10%
que il y a de plus en plus de sortes en
prison dans les centres de rétention ce
qui augmente la peur des policiers et
l'ambiance dégradée dans les centres de
rétention
moi j'ai vu des retenues s'accrocher à
moi et me dire Madame s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi à retourner en prison c'était
le paradis c'est pour vous dire mais le
fait que pourquoi les démarches ne
sont-elles pas entreprises quand les
gens sont en prison pour que les
expulsions
pour éviter le passage par le centre de
rétention qui est à la fois
c'est une ambiance horriblement
anxiogène parce que les gens
mine de rien ils jouent leur vie
là-dedans et est-ce qu'ils vont être
envoyés dans leur pays ou pas il y a
aussi tout le problème des jeunes
anciens jeunes anciens mineurs non
accompagné à qui des gens très
intelligents ont soufflé des conseils
très malins du style ne donne pas ton
pays d'origine dictée algérien alors tu
es tunisien déchirent tes papiers ce qui
fait que nous on est tombé au centre de
rétention de 7 sur un gamin qui avait 19
ans qui sanglotait du matin au soir il
voulait rentrer en Tunisie et bien ça
n'était plus possible et à mon avis il
rentrera jamais en Tunisie d'abord la
Tunisie reprend pas ses ressortissants
ou très peu ensuite aucune trace de lui
aucun papier de lui venant de Tunisie et
ils sont placés dans une situation
son père était en train de mourir là-bas
il pleurait il pleurait l'herbe de son
corps ensuite je signale autre chose à
la visite de Lyon c'est la première fois
qu'on fait deux articles 40 en une seule
visite
dont l'une parce qu'il y a un problème
de médecine dans les cas là les hospices
civils ont abandonné le gras la
convention entre le crâne et les
Hospices Civils de Lyon à sauté c'est
confié au privé il y a un médecin deux
après-midi par semaine c'est tout
alors que les gens sont souvent dans des
états très déprimés
et physiquement pas génial et surtout on
a vu des infirmières distribuées à tour
de bras un médicament qui s'appelle le
Lyrica je sais pas si vous le connaissez
c'est fait pour soigner les neuropathies
douloureuses et les accès de et les
crises d'épilepsie et ces distribués à
60% de la population du crâne qui sont
majorité des hommes jeunes ce qui rend
absolument impossible le fait que 60% de
jeunes personnes soient atteinte de ces
pathologies et de fait sont des calmants
puissants qui se revendent à 8 euros le
comprimé à travers le crâne il y a un
trafic mais qui est favorisé par le fait
que sans aucun coup contrôle
ces médicaments sont distribués comme ça